Millennials just kind of created the  culture that that gen Z is just  repelling and it really is like that  it's just it's like look at these lame  people like they don't know how to have  fun all they know how to do is uh  destroy things rather than yeah and  obviously there's exceptions but  yeah what do you think you think the  most Millennials are just just really  awful  um I do I think Millennials Millennials  you know it's it's a it's a terrible  generation jet I like Gen X I love Jenna  Gen X are relatively chill but some of  them are pretty bad like every  generation that's bad people it's not  it's not about like how old you are but  there's like actually I think boomers  are actually really great I think  Boomers have done done some things that  are really bad uh acquiescing uh or  giving in to and capitulating to is  probably a better word the woke nonsense  for Millennials gen xers kind of get  lost in between but Boomers gave us the  Next Generation